>>> TODAY A CLEAN SWEEP FOR MAGA
STYLE REPUBLICANIN NEW
HASHIRE, ALL THREE OF THE
STATE'S TRP ALIGNED
CONGRESSIONAL HOPEFULS WON THEIR
PRIMARY CONTESTS.
>> IN THE GOP SENATE RACE,
RETIRED ARMY GENERAL AND 2020
ELECTION DENIER DON DEFEATED
ESTABLISHMENT CANDIDATE CHUCK
MORRIS.
BOLDUC WILL FACE MAGGIE HASSIN.
JOINING US NOW, CONGRESSMAN WHAT
DOES IT SAY THAT ELECTION
DENIERS ONCE AGAIN, CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS BEAT THE MAIN STREAM
CANDIDATES BACKED BY MITCH
McCONNELL AND THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR?
HOW IS THIS HAPPENING?
>> WELL, REGRETTABLY, THIS IS
WHERE THE PARTY IS GOING AND
PART OF A TREND.
WE'VE SEEN, ALISYN, THE MAGA
CANDIDATES HAVE BEEN WINNING AND
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE THERE COULD BE
A CONSEQUENCE.
THE OTHER CANDIDATE MORRIS WAS
CONSIDERED TO BE MUCH MORE
ELECTABLE THAN BULDOC BUT THE
VOTERS MADE A CHOICE.
THEY GOT BULDOC.
HAVING SAID THAT, BULDOC COULD
STILL WIN.
IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE BUT MAKES IT
HARDER AND IN MANY CASES AROUND
THE COUNTRY REPUBLICANS
NOMINATED CANDIDATES SEEN AS TOO
EXTREME IN AND WILL MAKE THEIR
PATH TO THE SENATE AND HOUSE
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING.
>> IN SOME RACES, DO YOU BELIEVE
SINCE HISTORY SUGGESTS THAT THE
PARTY OUT OF POWER WILL LIKELY
TAKE CONTROL AND MAYBE THEY HAVE
SOME ADVANTAGES THERE IN THE
STATES BECAUSE OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS, SOME DENIERS WILL
GET INTO OFFICE AND LEAD THE
LEGISLATIVE AGENDAS OF CONGRESS?
>> OH, I DON'T THINK THAT'S AS
GREAT A RISK THAN IF THE MORE
MODERATE CANDIDATES HAD ONE.
I THINK IF THOSE CANDIDATES HAD
ONE, THEN YES, WHAT YOU JUST
SAID WOULD BE THE CASE.
I THINK THEY WOULD BE MORE
LIKELY TO END UP IN OFFICE.
I THINK THAT THESE ARE
CANDIDATES THAT VERY MUCH
RESONATE WITH THE BASE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT THEY DON'T
RESONATE WITH THE BROADER
ELECTRET.
THEY DON'T RESONATE WITH
INDEPENDENCE FOR EXAMPLE.
SO I THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE MUCH EASIER FOR DEMOCRATS TO
BEAT EVEN ALLOWING FOR THE FACT
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE THE PRESIDENT
AND THE PARTY IN POWER TENDS TO
DO WORSE, YOU KNOW, THAN THE
PARTY OUT OF POWER IN THE FIRST
MIDTERM ELECTIONS BUT I THINK
THAT THE REPUBLICANS ARE GIVING
DEMOCRATS A HOPE OF BEATING THAT
TREND BY NOMINATING PEOPLE WHO
ARE SO WIDELY OUT OF THE MAIN
STREAM.
>> I WANT TO STICK WITH YOU.
WHAT IS SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
DOING?
WHY IS HE PROPOSING --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THIS.
WHY IS HE PROPOSING A FEDERAL
ANTI ABORTION LAW THAT WOULD BAN
ALL ABORTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AT 15 WEEKS?
I DON'T THINK THAT HE
UNDERSTANDS HOW PREGNANCY WORKS?
YOU DON'T OFTEN GET TESTING,
IMPORTANT TESTING UNTIL 20
WEEKS.
WHAT IS THIS THAT HE'S DOING?
>> YEAH, WELL, I DON'T THINK HE
REALLY CARES TO UNDERSTAND IT,
AND HE, YOU KNOW, HE'S CLEARLY
ESTABLISHED HIMSELF AS SOMEBODY
WHO IS PRETTY EXTREME ON THIS
ISSUE.
I MEAN, HE HAD A PREVIOUS BILL
THAT WAS AT 20 WEEKS SO THIS ONE
IS WORSE THAN THAT ONE BUT THE
20 WEEK SPAN ALSO IS PRETTY BAD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING
BECAUSE HE'S -- YOU USUALLY LOOK
AT THESE THINGS AND THINK WELL,
THEY'RE DOING IT BECAUSE IT'S
HELPFUL POLITICALLY AND PERHAPS
HELPFUL TO HIM IN SOMEWAY BUT
NOT HELPFUL TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND THAT'S BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR IN THE WAY MITCH
McCONNELL'S RESPONDED TO IT
WHICH IS TO SAY, YOU KNOW, THAT
THE REPUBLICAN POSITION IS THAT
THEY BELIEVE THIS SHOULD BE
HANDLED BY THE STATES WHICH IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAID NOT THAT LONG AGO
AND NOW HAS TURNED AROUND AND
TRIED TO INTRODUCE THIS VERY
RADICAL LEGISLATION THAT WILL
DEFINITELY ALIENATE VOTERS.
>> YEAH.
YOU POINTED OUT THIS IS AGAIN
SOMETHING THAT LINDSEY GRAHAM
HIMSELF SAID.
THIS WAS SIX WEEKS AGO.
LET'S PLAY WHAT LINDSEY GRAHAM
SAID ABOUT WHAT THE STATE SHOULD
DETERMINE AND WHAT HE'S SAYING
ABOUT THIS NEW BILL.
>> I'VE BEEN CONSISTENT.
I THINK STATES SHOULD DECIDE THE
ISSUE OF MARRIAGE AND STATES
SHOULD DECIDE THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION.
I HAVE RESPECT FOR SOUTH
CAROLINA.
SOUTH CAROLINA VOTERS HERE I
TRUST TO DEFINE MARRIAGE AND TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF ABORTION.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A LAW AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT WOULD SAY
AFTER 15 WEEKS, NO ABORTION ON
DEMAND EXCEPT IN CASES OF RAPE,
INCEST TO SAVE THE LIFE OF THE
MOTHER.
IF WE TAKE BACK THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE, I CAN ASSURE YOU
WE'LL HAVE A VOTE ON OUR BILL.
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM REVERSING
HIMSELF ON A POSITION IS NOT NEW
BUT WHY THIS BILL THIS WHY RIGHT
NOW CONGRESSMAN?
>> WELL, LOOK, THERE IS A
CERTAIN INCOHERENCE TO THIS.
THE POSITION WAS LET THIS BE
HANDLED BY THE STATES AS LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAID PREVIOUSLY AND NOW
THEY WANT A 15-WEEK BAN THAT
COULD SUGGEST MAYBE REPUBLICANS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WOULD
SUPPORT ABORTION UP TO 15 WEEKS,
THE POINT IS HE'S INTRODUCING
THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE STATES
POST ROE ARE PASSING LAWS THAT
BAN ABORTION COMPLETELY WITH FEW
OR NO EXCEPTIONS AND THAT IS
POLITICALLY JUST OUTRAGEOUS AND
SO HE THINKS, I BELIEVE, THAT BY
INTRODUCING THIS BILL,
REPUBLICANS CAN LAND AT A BETTER
PLACE.
I WOULD ARGUE THIS IS BETTER
THAN WHAT THE STATES ARE DOING
BUT STILL INCOHERENT AS THE LAST
PRO-CHOICE REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF
THE U.S. HOUSE, I CAN TELL YOU
MANY REPUBLICANS ARE DISCOVERING
THAT PRE -- THAT PRE DOBBS THEY
WOULD PASS AND ENACT THESE BILLS
KNOWING THEY WOULD NEVER
NOW THAT THE BACKSTOP HAS BEEN
PULLED, THE GOALIE HAS BEEN
PULLED, SO TO SPEAK, THEY'RE NO
LONGER SHOOTING BLANKS.
THEY'RE SHOOTING LIVE ROUNDS ON
ABORTION.
THIS IS ONE MORE CASE.
I THINK THIS IS A BIT
INCOHERENT.
WHY DO YOU WANT A FEDERAL LAW
WHEN YOU'VE BEEN SAYING FOR
YEARS YOU WANT THE STATES TO
HANDLE IT.
I THINK THIS MUDDLES THE ISSUE
FURTHER AND MAY NOT PRESENT ANY
REAL POLITICAL ADVANTAGE TO
REPUBLICANS ON THIS ISSUE.
>> I WOULD ALSO SAY IT'S
TERRIBLE POLITICAL CALCULUS.
EVEN IN CONSERVATIVE STATES
YOU'VE SEEN PEOPLE SAYING THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE THESE BAN,
RIGHT?
WHAT LINDSEY GRAHAM IS SAYING IS
WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO DO IT IN
CONSERVATIVE STATES, BUT FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK -- WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IN THE STATES, THE
NON-RED STATES.
THESE JUST AREN'T VERY POPULAR.
THE LEADERS OF THE REPUBLICA